did you like Stephen King I did I only
met him one day he he came down to the
set at the beginning of shooting very
how would I describe what I remember as
Stephen King is shot a gentlemen the
gentleman a very yes soft-spoken
gentleman did he look like someone who
look you gotta have demons to write
that he writes no you don't think so no
I do
oh I think creative but why is it always
so dark there's something don't you
think there's something going on if 95
of what you're right is really really
dark
what's what's I don't I I have mixed
I have
I have mixed emotions about that makes
thinking about that right one of my
clients called and said Dee I'm taking
this other class and the teacher said
that anybody that is involved in horror
films in in any way is damaging their
energy and and their psychic I said well
I'm telling you that's
because would you tell a little
five-year-old girl who's playing a witch
in a play oh she's gonna damage her
psyche or or the kid that says I'm gonna
be the alligator and Peter Pan and come
get everybody that he's it's just
we're doing what we love that's
fantasy we are doing what we love that
makes us happy I'm glad you said that
because look at the movies around you
Evil Dead Lost Boys Jaws uh you know the
thing um Nightmare on Elm Street Dracula
Return of the Living Dead Friday the
13th I love horror movies and I start to
think is there something wrong with me I
don't think you should Google I want
everybody my mom want made me watch
horror movies with her from the time I
was eight just uh but go ahead oh
positive effects of horror films
you will be stunned write that down so I
remember it it does positive things for
your brain for your nervous system
it helps you learn how to deal with
trauma
so that's why every Disney film has a
really scary character in it
you know when we would watch
um The Little Mermaid my daughter would
go Mommy lady get big part lady get big
part where Ursula gets big and you know
she wanted to see that over and over
again so she could sit there in a in a
safe place like we do when we go to a
theater
and learn how to handle her fears
I mean seriously is there anything that
you've seen in the theater that's worse
than what's going on in our world